one time i hallucinated there was a
minor 49er sitting across the road from
me he had a big gray beard and you know
overalls on and i noticed he's got a
gold pan and he holds out the gold pan
to me and he says water
water i need water hi it's dean
carnassus author and ultramarathoner and
this is ultramarathon support
[Music]
from flamenco
cat how on earth do you eat and run
without up chucking or do you walk and
eat you do both you run and eat and walk
and eat i
eat a lot of food while i'm running and
a lot of ultra marathoners do because
you don't want to slow down it's always
about relentless forward progress i'll
be honest sometimes you know you do up
chuck it's not normal and you try not to
up chuck because up checking can create
electrolyte imbalances most of the time
the food stays down just fine but
depending on the temperature and the
duration you know up chucking can be a
problem so the next question is from
zizzo group do ultra marathon runners
pee their pants during a run not if
you're good at it i don't get any on my
shoes yes i pee while i run but not in
my pants that begs the question how do
you do it literally just kind of turn
sideways and you waddle like a like a
penguin and i'm expert at it i don't
even get a drop on my shoes
how do runners deal with nipple chafing
and that's a really good question there
is a product called nipple ease believe
it or not it's like a little round
band-aid there's nothing actually
touching your nipple but there's a like
a barrier in front of it next question
is from
l.e black sheep why why why is it such a
pain to get breathing technique right
when running that's another good
question i've been experimenting with
with nose breathing at a shorter
distance like a 10k only breathing
through my nose and what i found is it
really sucks but it gets you into very
good shape my friend bart yasso who's a
guy i greatly admire you know bart says
i breathe through my nose i breathe
through my mouth i breathe through any
way i can get air in my lungs so i think
it's very much a personal choice how you
breathe whether you breathe through your
mouth or through your nose but i would
encourage you to try nose breathing see
if that works for you if not breathe
your mouth as well
so this next question is from fiona how
in the world did dean carnassus run for
24 hours well it gets better than that i
ran for 24 hours on a treadmill on a
two-story platform hoisted above times
square with all the jumbotrons filming
me as i did this 24 hour run and as you
can imagine it was quite dizzying not
only being on a treadmill for 24 hours
but being up in the air trying to
complete this ultra marathon and it was
all for a very good cause it was a
fundraiser for prostate cancer so it
felt worthwhile and i think in the end i
covered about
148 miles but i didn't move a single
step forward it's crazy it's ludicrous
to be saying this but i've actually run
for 48 hours on a treadmill as well but
that's not the longest i've ever run
i've run for 81 hours and that was over
the course of 350 miles you know i think
it was the very last step i actually had
and 350 miles about killed me so next up
is kayla with a c at akwardi i have a
serious question how do runners control
their bms for hours on end of running we
carry toilet paper
that's a simple answer we look for a
strategic bush to hide behind and
typically dig a little hole you do your
thing and sometimes i even carry a
little bag and kind of pick it up like a
like a dog poop amber asks why do they
give out belt buckles at ultramarathons
just curious the legend is that the
hundred mile trail race began as a horse
race and one year a gentleman was
training to do this 100 mile horse race
and his horse came up lame three days
before the start but he still wanted to
do the race and he announced i'm just
gonna run it and they thought he was
crazy but they let him do the horse race
on foot and he somehow finished the race
and when he got to the finish line they
didn't have typical race medals because
this is a horse race but they did have
rodeo style belt buckles so they said
let's just give them one of those so
here is a very celebrated western states
100 mile endurance run silver buckle
when you finish the race 10 times in
under 24 hours each
you get one of these special buckles
mike asks it's very easy to get
discouraged after taking a long break
from running how do you get motivated to
get after it that's a really good
question and i empathize with you
because it is very difficult to get
motivated to restart i always suggest
investing in a good pair of shoes
footwear technology has advanced so much
in the past three or four years so part
of what's going to motivate you is that
if those shoes sit idle in your closet
you're going to feel so guilty you
didn't put them to use and then i would
say five to six months down the road
sign up for a race i would say a half
marathon or a marathon tell your friends
about it you know send out an email
blast saying hey i'm gonna do this this
half marathon and i'm gonna do it for
charity so will you support me and once
people are supporting you you know
you're kind of on the hook and then
ramp up your training slowly and realize
that it's baby steps it's much easier to
get out of shape than it is to get back
into shape i i sav-x how can i run
faster and the answer is
run faster
and what tends to happen is when we go
out for a run or a workout we push to
our max you hit a plateau i recommend
the hard easy technique so one day go
really really hard running as fast as
you can the next day slow down your pace
go a little bit further but slower but
you've got to run really fast beyond you
know your typical pace to be able to
improve beyond the plateau also i would
recommend quantifying your workouts you
can see here i have a smartwatch on i
like to look at a lot of different data
from my run just to see how the
improvements are coming along or not
coming along and making adjustments
based on that data scott johnson asks
what's the best way to carb load before
an ultramarathon and my answer is don't
i do not carb load and i do not
recommend carb loading i used to carb
load a lot and inevitably i show up the
next morning at the start of the race
bloated from carb loading the night
before so i recommend just having a
normal meal the night before a race i
would also suggest avoiding a lot of
dietary fiber for obvious reasons
especially insoluble fiber before a race
insoluble fiber makes you regular but
during a race you don't want to be
regular the idea behind carb loading was
to improve your muscle glycogen stores
so your muscles only store a certain
amount of carbohydrates it's called
glycogen and the theory was if you ate
more carbohydrates you'd store more
glycogen
but the problem is that's not always the
case and the other problem is that you
store a lot of water when you carb load
so you end up feeling bloated so the
next question comes from
lisa
bardelt how did you get started i assume
no one becomes an ultra marathoner
overnight well i'll tell you my my
backstory i walked out of a bar on my
30th birthday and decided that night i
was going to run 30 miles and my friends
thought i was crazy they said let's have
another round of tequila to celebrate
your 30th birthday and i said no i'm
going to run 30 miles instead and at
midnight i left the bar and i'll never
forget i didn't own running gear but i
had on these these comfortable silk
boxer shorts these silk underwear so i
peeled off my pants and threw them down
the alleyway i lived in san francisco at
the time and i knew there was a city
called half moon bay that was 30 miles
away and i thought just run to half moon
bay and about 15 miles into it i sobered
up and i thought what am i doing this is
crazy but it just felt right
and the other thing is that you know i
was out in the middle of nowhere at this
point so there's nowhere to go but
forward turning around would have been
another 15 miles to get back so that
night i made it 30 miles it wasn't
pretty there was some you know some
blistering and some chafing where the
sun don't shine it forever changed the
course of my life and after that i
became an ultra marathoner hannah asks
what do you all think about during a run
mundane stuff or big ideas or how much
you just want to die
i think you think of all of those things
you know when i'm running an ultra
marathon or a long distance i think of
everything and nothing many runners
that's why we love what we do is because
your mind is free to wander you know
you're kind of a captive audience of one
and sometimes i think about big issues
other times i think about just taking my
next step when things get really
difficult i try to turn off the mind and
not think at all and just put one foot
in front of the other to the best of my
ability the other thing i do a lot of
when i'm running is writing so i've
written five books and i do a lot of
writing on the run gilly gilly how do
runners find their second win when i
can't even find my first win
sometimes i have a hard time finding my
first win as well but i would say push
through it you know perseverance a lot
of it just comes down to grunt work
don't be afraid to walk if you have to
walk take a walk break but keep going
the important thing is that you keep
pushing and it will get easier there's
all kinds of theories why energy you
know comes in waves something called the
central governor theory which is your
mind regulates it all there's theories
where your body basically
physiologically tells your mind to slow
down because you know you're getting
into the red zone but a lot of it i
think is very subjective you know during
an ultra marathon you might go through a
second third fourth fifth sixth seventh
eighth and ninth and tenth wind you're
constantly kind of hitting the wall
you're out of gas and you're out of
breath and if you can push through it
you have some renewed energy and you can
keep going you run when you can you walk
if you have to you crawl if you must you
just never give up
so the next question is from
ben schlong
the fantasy flyer how do you train for
an ultra marathon when the joints are
saying no the hashtag is aging well i
feel you there ben i'm i'm no
spring chicken myself
but one thing i would recommend is cross
training to me the big secret staying
injury-free and pain-free is
cross-training so i do a lot of training
with my leg strength and also my upper
body strength it also say you know your
diet is very important so boosting the
omega-3 fatty acids from you know fatty
seafoods is one way to um you know keep
your joints lubricated so one tool you
might want to incorporate for your
recovery is something called a
percussion gun it hammers your muscle a
lot of runners and ultra marathoners use
these not only in between races for
recovery but actually on the course they
might come into an aid station have
their crew member there just take it
usually to their quadriceps or to their
calves i'm in my 50s now i still run
ultra marathons and 100 mile or further
ultra marathons and i'm not the only one
there are other people in their 50s 60s
even 70s that are running ultra
marathons so i don't think we have a
limited number of foot strikes in our
life i think it just comes down to the
individual and training but i really
believe that anyone can run an ultra
marathon and they can keep running ultra
marathons even as they age at go run
with me i love that handle how do you
fuel up during an ultra marathon looking
at nutrition options for big races i
would say listen to everyone follow no
one jessica
you have to find what works best for you
so experiment during your training run
you know for me i use a product called
heed by hammer nutrition which is a
scientifically engineered energy drink i
also use you know gels energy bars i
also personally like nut butters so it's
a nut butter is a very concentrated
source of calories one element of ultra
marathon especially during hot
ultramarathons is hydration so staying
well hydrated and maintaining your
electrolyte balance is is very important
not only do i you know we drink a lot of
water but we also drink electrolyte
replenishment beverages that also have a
source of carbohydrates of complex
carbohydrates not simple sugars product
i use to stay hydrated as well is called
endurolites it's like a salt capsule but
it has magnesium potassium chloride and
endurolites also have ginger powder
which helps settle your stomach so i'd
experiment with using either s-caps or
enduro lights to see how they help you
maintain your electrolyte balance yeah
so during a typical ultra marathon we
wear what are called hydration packs
they have pouches and packs where you
can store these things during your run
they also have some pockets in the front
and that's how you can grab these things
on the run the first time i tried to run
the bad water ultra marathon which is a
135 mile race across death valley in the
middle of summer i became extremely
dehydrated and i threw my electrolytes
out of balance and at about mile 75 at
2am i passed out on the side of the road
and my crew was driving all around the
desert looking for me and they saw two
shoes sticking out of a bush and they
literally picked me up and they carried
me to the car and they drove me three
hours to the nearest hotel and i fell
asleep for eight hours
and that's when my first ultra marathon
ended and you know i've had some really
vivid hallucinations i've hallucinated
there were dinosaurs off in the distance
and and one time i hallucinated there
was a minor 49er sitting across the road
from me he had a big gray beard and you
know overalls on and i noticed he's got
a gold pan and he holds out the gold pan
to me and he says water
water i need water and i was carrying a
handheld water bottle so i aspirated it
in his gold pan
and i heard the water sizzling on the
pavement and i reached out to touch him
and my hand went right through him and i
thought he's not real that was a
hallucination so the next question is
from
john mulkin question for runners
what's the etiquette when you're out
running and you're approaching another
person in front you trip them
no i'm just kidding john do what feels
natural to you some runners prefer just
to keep their head down and run past
another runner others like to to wave or
you know at least acknowledge the other
runner some like to give high fives so
do whatever feels right for you and you
really can't do anything wrong giving
another runner some love so the next
question is from
julie gross why does the same distance
in time feel so different on different
days and how do you deal with those runs
when you just feel terrible and that's a
really good question it might have to do
with your state of recovery or even your
sleep sometimes if you get a bad night's
sleep the next day running cannot feel
as good as the previous day might also
be your psychological state you know if
you're on a downer if you will sometimes
your body just responds accordingly just
the opposite is true sometimes when
you're just in an upbeat mood you have
some of the best runs ever it's just
little subtle things that can play a big
role in how you feel during a run so the
next question is from misha goravich
how do ultra marathon runners not get
bored do they listen to podcasts i
listen to audiobooks actually i've got
over 500 audiobooks on my playlist so i
listen to a lot of audiobooks sometimes
i just tune out and listen to the
beating of my heart those are all the
questions for today you really asked
some quirky and some interesting
questions so i learned a lot and i hope
you did as well
[Music]
you